en fait le point ce soir avec
l'économiste roxane borgès da silva
professeur agrégé à l'école de santé
publique de l'université de montréal
bonsoir bonsoir les étudiants alors est
ce qu'il faut selon vous et jusqu'où
dans quelle mesure fermer davantage
l'économie au québec
en fait il faut savoir qu'actuellement
tous les voyants sont au rouge
le nombre de cas ne cesse d'augmenter
les hospitalisations ce ton en fait les
auspices des hôpitaux sont débordés les
soins intensifs également et on n'a pas
réussi à renverser la tendance avec les
confinements partiel qui ont été mis en
place
alors dans cette situation là selon moi
le gouvernement n'a pas de choix
d'autres choix que de mettre en place
des mesures strictes mais mais surtout
des mesures qui vont être efficace et on
n'a plus de marge de manoeuvre on peut
plus faire de laisser erreur à ce stade
ci il faut trouver des mesures qui soit
efficace à 100% tout renverser cette
tendance des cas comme quoi par exemple
quelles mesures seraient efficaces
alors c'est sûr que l'australie où
l'australie l'angleterre la nouvelle
zélande et même nous au mois de mars
dernier on l'a vu un confinement complet
est une mesure efficace est ce que c'est
ce que le gouvernement de mettre en
place je le sais pas le gouvernement a
toutes sortes de paramètres aussi qu'il
sur lesquels il peut jouer il ya un une
autre mesure qui a été très efficace en
france qui a été le couvre feu en
mettant en instaurant un couvre feu non
respect on responsabilise les individus
un parent eux mêmes puisqu'ils doivent
au moment du couvre-feu s'ils doivent
sortir remplir une déclaration et ils
vont se poser la question à savoir si la
sortie du domicile est vraiment
nécessaire donc en responsabilisant la
population peut être ça pourrait être un
moyen également de réduire le nombre de
cas ça a été très efficace en france
couvre feu à 18 à 20 ou à 21h avec des
des policiers dans les rues c'est ça oui
tout à fait en fait les personnes qui
sortent de leurs maisons après l'heure
du couvre-feu doit justifier par une
déclaration sur l'honneur de la raison
en fait pour laquelle ils sont sortis de
chez eux
est-ce qu'il faut fermer le secteur
manufacturier
et je pense aux abattoirs en trop qui a
quand même pas mal de cas d'éclosion
danser dans ce type d'entreprises
c'est sûr que le secteur manufacturier
est un gros enjeu dans la mesure où
c'est le milieu de travail on voit le
plus d'éclosion actuellement si c'est
encore au gouvernement de décider s'il
faut le fermer ou pas dans lequel un
confinement strict évidemment il sera
fermé
mais s'il n'est pas fermée il faut
absolument mettre en place des mesures
de prévention promotion éducation pour
rappeler et de contrôle aussi pour
rappeler le bon la bonne façon de porter
le masque les mesures de distanciation
physique et le lavage des mains qui
somme toute voix on voit à laisser aller
dans ces aspects là le docteur horacio
arruda le disais au dernier point de
presse faut-il repousser à plus tard le
retour à l'école
au delà de en janvier et bien c'est sûr
que pour les élèves du secondaire on a
vu on l'a expérimenté les cours en ligne
c'est somme toute un parfait mais c'est
faisable il ça permet des deux contre
deux
en fait de circonscrire les explosions
dans les écoles secondaires pour les
écoles primaires
c'est en fait on sait pas encore si on a
le variant de l'angleterre
actuellement en circulation et on sait
que des études vient de sortir et disent
que les enfants en baie les enfants en
bas de 10 ans sont aussi contagieux que
les adolescents et les adultes avec ce
variant là dans tous les cas ce qui est
sûr c'est que les écoles primaires les
enfants en fait scolarisés au primaire
ou un très grand besoin de socialisation
besoins d'apprentissage et quand ils ne
sont pas capables en fait ne sont pas
autonomes pour rester en ligne toute la
journée
comme leurs frères ou soeurs du
secondaire et la charge revient aux
parents de faire l'enseignement en ligne
et de suivre leurs enfants
donc dans ce contexte moi je prendrais
de laisser le plus possible les écoles
primaires ouvertes mais si sûr que à
l'impossible nul n'est tenu
mais sait on peut se poser des questions
à savoir s'il faut prolonger ou non dans
les écoles s'il faut fermer le secteur
manufacturier si on devrait aussi
ralentir les activités dans dans la
construction mais on le voyait encore ce
matin docteur françois marquis qui
disait que cette cassure 9 à maisonneuve
rosemont heureusement 7 sur 9 quand même
avoue ne pas avoir respecté les règles
est ce qu'on comprend que le message
tout simplement ne passe plus absolument
en fait il semble que les gens sont
tannés les gens veulent plus respecté
les règles et il a période des fêtes de
noël est particulière puisque les gens
avaient ce besoin de rassemblement
pendant les fêtes c'est une tradition
c'est une tradition importante au québec
donc dans ce contexte c'était la période
à pire pour la contamination et et on
l'a vu les gens une bonne partie des
gens n'ont pas respecté les
rassemblements espérons que peut-être
avec d'autres mesures que le
gouvernement mettra en place on pourra
avoir un plus grand respect des mesures
et finalement une baisse des cas est ce
que le gouvernement a donc raté sa cible
selon vous durant temps des fêtes en ne
fermant pas complètement l'économie mais
vous vous rappelez certainement qu on
était 80 experts
tracy et lettre ouverte au début du mois
de décembre demandant au gouvernement de
mettre en place un confinement complet
pendant le congé scolaire et d'en
profiter puisque les coûts de l'économie
roule au ralenti pendant le congé
scolaire
le gouvernement a décidé de laisser les
commerces ouverts jusqu'au 24 décembre
le gouvernement a décidé aussi de
laisser ouvertes les industries
manufacturières
c'est au gouvernement de tirer des
leçons de tout ça mais mais c'est sûr
que on aurait peut-être pu faire mieux
donc c'était une erreur
c'est si possible oui parfait on verra
demain de toute façon le premier
ministre va faire des annonces à 17h dos
mais merci beaucoup merci bien pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez vous sur
la chaîne ici r d
oh